i always feel like at the beginning of
these videos i look like a dumpster fire
like
you know i grow my beard out and
suddenly i've got this dumpster fire on
my face and they're like hi i'm maddie
conrad i'm a men's grooming expert hey
gq it's maddie conrad and i'm back so is
my beard but today we're gonna focus on
something different that charismatic
cultural icon the mustache
throughout history the mustache has been
a bold statement of confidence and
affluence for many fashionable men
around the turn of the century a very
tight tailored mustache became very very
vogue i think guys like clark gable and
errol flynn these guys exuded style and
a lot of it was wrapped up in their
upper lip george harrison in the 1960s
just about everybody in the 1970s
nothing embodies the 1980s mustache like
tom selleck hollywood a-listers like
johnny depp brad pitt idris elba and
eddie murphy all of them know how to
rock a properly tamed tash and today
we're going to go through several styles
that are going to give you a little bit
of a better idea of which one might be
perfect for you some guys can grow a
burly thick mustache and other guys not
so much but that doesn't mean that there
isn't a mustache shape for everyone so
the tools i'm going to be using today
are an adjustable clipper to remove the
bulk a trimmer for outlining a fine
tooth comb from my mustache and i'm
going to use a wide tooth comb for my
beard
[Music]
so i've grown my beard back out but
along the way there are a few styles and
shapes that i kind of wanted to come
back to today i'm going to turn this
into a style that a lot of you have
referred to as a beard stash but i call
it the brogue now this kind of style is
usually a very amplified and pronounced
mustache with a much tighter looking
trimmed down beard so that the mustache
is more prominent than the beard itself
so what i'm going to do first is i'm
going to use my comb to protect the
length of my mustache by combing it out
of the way i'm then going to take my
adjustable clipper with a number two
guard and i'm going to work downwards to
remove the bulk of the beard on the
sides
i'm always working downwards because i
want a smoother finish as soon as i go
upwards into the beard i'm gonna lose a
lot more hair than i wanted to now i
don't want to take everything right down
to a number two because that's going to
leave my beard maybe a little shorter
than i want it and i want to maintain
just a little bit of beard shape i'm
going to take my clipper without a guard
inverted and i'm going to punch a line
from where i want the length of the
beard to be right towards my adam's
apple i'm going to do this right across
to create a nice strong ledge along the
bottom that is going to peek up slightly
into the corner rather than flat and
square
now to create a more pronounced mustache
i need to take the hair on my chin a
little shorter so i'm going to go back
to my number two guard
i'm going to lift my mustache up the
opposite way and then we're going to
work downwards over the chin
[Music]
now that we've got the shape roughed in
and relatively cleaned up one of the
more important things about this kind of
style is the outline and the outline is
why i call it the brogue once the shape
is put in and we create that rounded
outline on top it looks like the pattern
you'd find on top of a brogue shoe
creating the outline for a brogue style
is gonna require an electric trimmer and
the electric trimmer is gonna get things
really nice and tidy and outlined the
most important line of this entire shape
is the top line if you're somebody that
has a very full face shape you want that
line to be as straight and linear as
possible but if you're somebody with a
more narrow face shape or even a
standard face shape you want that line
to be slightly curved i'm going to
create a top line that goes from the
corner of my sideburns right towards the
point of my mustache and to create that
nice curvature i'm going to take my skin
i'm going to stretch it upwards and i'm
going to punch a straight line right
down from the corner of my sideburn
towards the corner of my mustache
now you want to make sure that your
mustache really stands out so i'm going
to push the mustache down and i can see
a little hair in the corner you want to
remove all that hair and the easiest way
to do that is by turning the trimmer the
flat side and working away from that
line that you've created
much better let's do that on the
opposite side
[Music]
now we need to tackle your baseline and
this is the line that we put in right at
the bottom of the beard we want to make
sure that's really nice and clean and
drops slightly towards the jawline to
create that fuller jaw shape so i'm
going to take my line here and just
clean up what i've already created to
make sure it's nice and crisp i'm then
going to take the hair on my neck as
tight as i can take it with my trimmer
to get this line even on both sides the
best trick is to make sure you keep
looking straight ahead don't turn your
head because you won't be able to see
this side when you're working on this
side keep your head straight into the
mirror and use the angle of your trimmer
to create your line
now we want to make sure that the back
line is cleaned up these are the little
hairs that grow backwards over the
jawline it also grows into your ears and
that's the stuff that when it gets long
means it's time for a haircut
[Music]
now that we've got the beard shape it's
time to focus on the feature of today's
style which is the mustache every
mustache is broken down into two parts
the peak which is the center part of the
mustache and the points which is the
outer part of the mustache so for a
shape like this i like to create a
slightly shorter peak and longer points
now you can use a trimmer which is going
to create a really hard clean line or if
you want something more organic you can
use a small pair of scissors
for longer mustaches i like to use
scissors it creates a softer look so to
do that i'm going to take a comb and i'm
going to comb my mustache straight down
you can see when i comb my mustache down
it already creates a natural kind of
horseshoe or like a peak over top of my
lip but mustaches should flow out to the
sides so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to create a center line using my
comb i'm going to place it under my nose
and i'm going to pull the hair on one
side of my mouth out of the way
then i'm going to start in the center
and i'm going to create a nice peak
shape using my scissors working
downwards
now that we've cleaned up the peak it's
time to deal with the points of the
mustache now these are going to be kind
of a personal choice some guys like
really long curly cue kind of styles and
some guys just like them to be really
nice and clean and that can best be done
by just taking them with a comb and
working on the outside cleaning
whatever's left over now the further you
take your comb down the longer
the outside of the points is going to be
but i also have a different way that i
like to do this because i like more of
an old-timey style to my mustache
there's lots of guys that i've seen that
have curly little mustaches that look
really thick and bushy in the middle
with little waxed tip points and i don't
like that i like mine to still look kind
of natural so the trick that i like to
use is i take a matte texturizing
product to put into my mustache to get a
little bit of control before i use a
blow dryer and some heat to shape it the
way i want it i'm going to use a little
bit of a matte finish paste here called
superdrive by victory barber of brandt
just a tiny amount and i'm going to work
it between my fingertips and work it
into my mustache before i hit it with a
blow dryer
now already you can start to see
that it creates a little bit of an
uptick but like most guys i always seem
to have one side that does it really
easily and one side that wants to flop
down that's why i'm going to use my blow
dryer i'm going to take my comb and my
blow dryer and i'm going to use high
heat the reason i use high heat when i'm
styling facial hair is because facial
hair acts very much like plastic does
when you heat it up it gets really soft
and bendy and when you cool it down
again it gets rigid and stiff just like
plastic so i'm gonna heat my hair up
sculpt it into shape and then i'm gonna
cool it down in the shape that i want it
so the first thing i'm gonna do is take
my comb create a center line and push
one side out of the way then i'm going
to use my air flow to direct the hair in
the opposite direction on my lip to make
sure that it spreads apart rather than
just hangs straight down
i'm then going to use the airflow
pointed upwards at the ends which is
going to create more of my curve
once i'm finished i'm going to take just
a little tiny bit more product to get
rid of the frizz
and make sure that mustache looks nice
and solid
now that we have the mustache styled and
shaped i can see just little frizzy guys
pointing off the ends of the points and
i want those to look relatively solid
and balanced on either side so what i'm
going to do then is just take my
scissors and i'm going to take off the
very tips to make sure
they're nice and even
[Music]
handsome no
what do you think
now that we've created my stylish stash
let's show you a few of the other
options you can look for on some of my
clients
[Music]
this mustache is made popular in the
1960s and carried right through until
the 1980s when it was made most famous
by hulk hogan it's very commonly
misreferred to as a handlebar mustache
but a handlebar mustache is in fact a
longer mustache that has a twisty rise
to it on the ends and looks like a
handlebars of an old bicycle now the
classic horseshoe has two sidelines that
drop right down and terminates somewhere
around the chin but the more modern
horseshoe breaks just below the bottom
lip my first client is gerb and he has a
slightly rounder face shape and we're
gonna do a classic horseshoe style on
him now for guys with fuller face shapes
i don't always like to shave all of the
rest of the hair completely off the face
they have a tendency to look a little
bit better if we leave just a tight
stubble because it allows us to do a
little bit of contouring and make his
face look leaner to create a tight
stubble for gerb i'm going to take a
number one guard on my adjustable
clipper and i'm going to run all the way
around his face making sure that i
protect the areas where i want to keep
the mustache
those are usually inside the smile line
areas once we've done that i'm going to
outline it using my trimmer to create a
nice strong shape on his jaw and then
we're going to outline the top line
using a straight razor at this point i
want to try and keep the line as angular
as possible to give him a leaner look
once we've established the shape of the
mustache making sure that we've left the
sides nice and long i'm going to clean
up the edges lightly using a pair of
scissors if i turn the scissors on their
side i'm not going to be cutting into
the stubble i'll just be able to create
a slightly cleaner outline for the
mustache and the imperial so now that
we've completed a classic horseshoe on
gerb you can see that it's a little
rougher looking it's a little more
organic and it's not perfectly polished
up this creates more of a feeling of a
70s style mustache and has a little bit
more of a badass vibe which really is
the point of this kind of a mustache
[Music]
the way to transition between a classic
horseshoe and a modern horseshoe is just
about the length of the sidelines
classic horseshoe the lines are going to
terminate somewhere around the chin for
a modern horseshoe that line is going to
terminate somewhere just below the
bottom lip a cleaner more modern version
of this mustache can be seen on
celebrities like the weeknd or idris
elba these guys have got their mustache
tamed down nice and tight and they've
reduced the length of those sidelines to
just below their mouths one of the
things you're going to find very
commonly accompanying this type of
mustache is a little patch of hair below
the bottom lip that we refer to as the
imperial now that's there to stretch out
the face shape if you're somebody with a
slightly fuller face shape that's
looking for a more elongated look than a
mustache will provide you then just
leave that little patch of hair below
your lip you'll be surprised what a
difference it makes in elongating the
shape of your face so to transition this
style into a more modern version of a
horseshoe we're gonna take the sides of
the mustache and we're gonna raise them
up instead of having them terminate at
the chin we're actually gonna bring
those up a little bit so they drop down
below the sides of the mouth just
slightly a good way to determine how
long these should be is to take your
comb and place it in the divot between
your lower lip and your chin
keep your comb level at that point is
where we should terminate the ends of
the mustache
we're also going to take the edges of
the mustache and define them more
clearly giving it a slightly more
squared look
this is going to give it a more modern
appearance and make you look just a
little bit trimmer and tidier this style
of mustache is perfect for a fuller face
shape because it creates a slightly more
elongated look even though the points
don't go all the way down to the chin
just drawing them down past the mouth
slightly stretches the bottom of the
face and gives you a leaner look
my next client is jason and jason has
something that a lot of guys run into
where their mustache doesn't necessarily
connect to the rest of their beard and
there's a little patch that doesn't seem
to want to grow hair he also has a
narrow face shape which means he's ideal
for being able to take this down nice
and clean so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take down the cheeks using just
my trimmer which is going to leave just
a tiny hint of stubble now i'm not going
to remove that entirely quite yet
because what we're going to create for
him is an anchored mustache style and an
anchored mustache style means that the
top is a strong mustache but there's a
disconnected small beard underneath and
creates kind of an anchor shape
to create this we're going to make sure
that we work inside the smile lines and
create a clear definition between the
mustache and the beard one of the most
important things about trying to keep
this as a contained style is making sure
that the beard component is inside the
points of the mustache
this kind of style has a little bit more
of a grunge feel to it
guys like johnny depp can be seen
wearing this pretty regularly
there's a reason why i didn't take all
the stubble away it gives it just a
slightly more lived in feel this is an
ideal style for guys that have ultra
sparse growth on their cheeks or guys
that have a disconnected mustache from
the rest of their beard it still gives
you lots of style points but doesn't
amplify the struggles that you're having
trying to fill in your cheeks or that
little point right next to your mouth
[Music]
tom selleck's mustache shape is what we
refer to as a chevron and the chevron is
basically paralleled on both sides two
square shapes that descend towards the
outside of the lip and break just at the
corner of the mouth now a classic
chevron is going to be left a little
fuller and a little thicker
but the modern chevron is shorter leaner
and cleaner most recently you're going
to be able to see this mustache style on
actors like mellow ventimiglia and joe
jonas
but this kind of mustache does require a
bit of a thicker girth on your upper lip
so it's not an ideal style if you only
grow a few whiskers up top there a
chevron mustache has a strong baseline
that's angled slightly down from the
center and the exact same angle is
mimicked for the top of the mustache
from the nostrils down out towards the
outside of the mouth i'm gonna start by
removing the goatee but i'm still gonna
leave a little bit of an imperial i'm
not sure why i just really like the way
this looks
then we're gonna really clearly outline
the mustache and make sure all of the
lips are cleaned up above the top lip
and the outline is nice and square
now this is a slightly leaner looking
mustache that extends past the corners
of the mouth outwards this is kind of a
cooler old-school look
think
old hollywood vibes on this one
this kind of mustache is a little
thicker in the middle and is tapered
down to slightly tighter points at the
end it's also usually notched out in the
center to create a nice clean center
line separating both sides of the
mustache
this type of mustache can be left a
little longer like this to create more
of a pronounced looking style this is an
excellent choice for guys that don't
have super thick growth on their upper
lip to create this kind of a mustache
you want to start by setting a really
strong lip line
make sure that it's nice and square and
extends from the high point in the
middle and descends slightly towards the
outside of the lip
then we're going to start reducing the
length on top of the lip we want to
leave this thicker in the middle so
we're going to create a slightly steeper
point going from the inside of the
nostril all the way down towards the
point of the mustache to balance out the
imperial we're going to take our
scissors from the corner of the mustache
and angle them downward this is going to
create sort of a diamond shape that's
going to balance out the shape of the
mustache
[Music]
this is one of my favorite styles of
mustache because
it's a strong look in the 1920s guys
like clark gable and errol flynn wore
this kind of mustache and they just
exuded a certain kind of charisma and
charm and confidence to start this
mustache we're going to further clean up
the lip line to make sure that it sits
just above the upper lip then we're
going to angle our trimmer down and
we're going to push the mustache down on
top to make it thinner and make sure
that that point is aiming right towards
the corner of the mouth
to further amplify this we're going to
reduce the size of the imperial
and we're going to clean up all of the
rest of the stubble on the face until he
looks clean shaven
and you know what i've changed my mind
let's get rid of the imperial altogether
[Music]
there you have it gq now you know how to
shave seven different mustache styles
now if you are a little bit hesitant
about getting a mustache and not sure if
you have what it takes to wear one
yourself just remember it's not what
you're wearing it's how you wear it
people are mostly attracted to
confidence i really believe that there's
a mustache for every personality type
out there and as always if you're having
trouble trying to find that perfect
facial hairstyle for you go and see your
barber they're full of great advice and
can help you get the exact look that
you're going for thanks a lot for
joining me again today gq check out all
of our other videos for all of your
facial hair grooming needs
and until i see you next time good luck
and good grooming
[Music]